meet the virus hunters a team of Thai
scientists who identify emerging
diseases
but since January they've had one
mission to help the government detect
the new coronavirus they've already cut
the results waiting time down from
almost two days to just three hours the
early detection and the fast liquidating
the Lisa not not just good early for the
the patient it is good also good for the
government so if it is positive they can
find the other contacts to not make the
disease spread 1,500 specimens have
already been analyzed here that includes
repeat screening of patients and any of
their possible contacts first the virus
is killed and the DNA is extracted
that's then separated into containers so
it can be tested to prove if it's
coronavirus or not the reason we're not
wearing full biohazard suits in this
room but the scientists next door are is
for one simple reason and that's because
the virus in that room is live
everything that comes into here is dead
and because coronavirus isn't
transferred through the air as an
aerosol it's transferred through
droplets this room has been deemed safe
dr. supper porn identified the first
case of coronavirus in thailand the lab
is one of only two in the country
testing positive samples while others
screen for potential sufferers an expert
in her field she's previously examined
bats monkeys and rodents for the sources
of coronaviruses flus Anabella we also
characterized the genome of the virus
and then the genome Abuela's can be used
to design the the medicine the drug and
other vaccine more collect Li and we
also used this genome to follow up to
monitor the mutation the research here
isn't just adding to local knowledge but
can be shared with teams around the
world as Thailand plays its part in the
global fight against this new threat
Siobhan Robbins Sky News Bangkok